[Music]
the country of fulin also called darchen
lies above the western sea in the
southeast it borders on poor sea its
territory amounts to over 10,000 Li of
cities there are 400 inhabited places
are close together the eaves pillars and
window bars of the palaces are
frequently made with crystal and opaque
glass there are 12 government ministers
who can jointly regulate government
matters the ordinarily let a man take a
bag and follow the Kings carriage when
the people have a complaint they throw a
written statement into the bag when the
King comes back to the palace he decides
between right and wrong the Kings are
not permanent rulers but they select men
of Merit if an extraordinary calamity
visits the country or if wind and rain
come at the wrong time
he is deposed and another man is put in
his stead the king's cap is shaped like
a bird raising its wings its trimmings
are beset with precious pearls
he wears silk embroidered clothing
without a lapel in front he sits on a
throne with golden ornaments he has a
bird like a goose its feathers of green
and it always sits on a cushion by the
side of the king whenever anything
poisonous has been put into the Kings
meals
the bird will crow
the walls of their capital are built of
granite and are of enormous height the
city contains in all over 100,000
households in the south it faces the
Great Sea in the east of the city there
is a large gate its height is over 20
Chang is beset with yellow gold from top
to bottom and shines at a distance of
several e coming from outside to the
royal residence there are three large
gates beset with all kinds of rare and
precious stones on the upper floor of
the second gate they have suspended a
large golden scale twelve golden balls
are suspended from the scale stick by
which the 12 hours of the day are shown
a human figure has been made all of gold
of the size of a man standing upright on
whose side whenever an hour has come one
of the golden balls will drop the
Dingling sound of which makes known the
divisions of the day without the
slightest mistake in the palaces pillars
are made of saysay the floors of yellow
gold the leaves of folding-doors of
ivory beams of fragrant wood
I have no tiles but powdered plaster is
rammed down into the floor above a house
this floor is perfectly firm and of
glossy appearance like jade stone
when during the height of summer the
inhabitants are oppressed by heat they
lead water up and make it flow over the
platform spreading it all over the roof
by a secret contrivance so that one sees
and knows not how it is done but simply
hears the noise of a well on the roof
suddenly you see streams of water
rushing down from the four eaves like a
cataract the draught caused thereby
reduces a cooling wind which is due to
this skillful contrivance it is
customary for men to have their hair cut
and wear robes leading the right arm
their women have no lapels on their
dresses they wear turbans of embroidered
cloth the possession of a great fortune
confers superior rank on its owner
there are lambs that grow in the ground
the inhabitants wait till they're about
to sprout and then screen them off by
building walls to prevent the beasts
which are at large
outside from eating them up the navel of
these lambs is connected to the ground
when it is forcibly cut the animal will
die but after the people have fixed the
buds themselves they frighten them by
their steps of horses or the beating of
drums when the lambs will yield a sound
of alarm and the navel will be detached
and then the animal may be separated
from the water plant the inhabitants are
in the habit of cutting their hair and
wearing embroidered clothing they drive
in small carriages with wipped canopies
when going in or out they beat drums and
hoist flags banners and pennants the
country contains much gold silver and
rare gems
there is the jewel that shines at night
the moon shine pearl the chicken
frightening rhinoceros stone large
conscious the mother-of-pearl carnelian
stones jadeite corals amber and all the
valuable curiosities of the West are
exported from this country the emperor
young sea of the Sui dynasty always
wished to open intercourse with fulin
but did not succeed in the 17th year of
the period Changwon the king of fulin
sent an embassy offering red glass green
gold gems and other articles thai song
favored them with a message under his
imperial seal and graciously granted
presence of silk
since the tar she had conquered these
countries they sent their
commander-in-chief mowie to beseech
their capital city by means of an
agreement they obtained friendly
relations and asked to be allowed to pay
every year tribute of gold and silk in
the sequel they became subject to Tashi
in the second year of the period xi'an
thing they sent an embassy in the first
year of the period tasu they again sent
an embassy to our court in the first
month of the seventh year of the period
kaiyuan their Lord sent an officer of
high rank to kazahstan to offer lions
and antelopes two of each a few months
after he further sent priests or great
virtue to our court with tribute
[Music]
you